we begin in atlanta with charles watson
for the latest hi charles
good morning david majority leader
mcconnell again shooting down another
attempt to
give a 2 000 stimulus checks to the
american people essentially putting him
at odds with georgia's republican
senators
just three days out from election day
senators
david perdue and kelly lafler are among
only a handful
of republican senators who have publicly
come out in support of president trump's
demand for two thousand dollar stimulus
checks
the pair have little room to break from
the president
as they look for his support to help
them fend off tough competition
from democrats jon ossoff and rafael
warnock respectively
and in a rare instance of agreement
warnock and ossoff agree
with both leftler and purdue when it
comes to upping direct payments to the
american people the two democrats have
used the issue on the campaign trail
as they try to pull off another blue win
in georgia
i think it's shameful we should have
passed relief months ago
and this is what happens when the
politics becomes about the politicians
when you look at it this is a lot of
maneuvering between politicians
and they live a kind of privilege that
allows them to do that
and leader mcconnell has dismissed the
two thousand dollar stimulus check says
quote universal cash giveaways
and said it was not the right approach
to provide targeted relief so it'll be
interesting david to see
if that hurts or helps republicans as
election day approaches
it's going to be critical very
interesting charles thank you very much